I love real life crime stories I think
we are tapping into figuring out
Mysteries figuring out crimes audiences
are really into True Crime con stories
things that have to do with the internet
what missing is doing is taking that
Fascination and putting it into the
devices that we use every day it's a
huge Maze of red herring sometimes we
describe it as a puzzle or a math
problem you want to subvert people's
expectations and keep things as a
surprise they're all obsessed with
people using the internet to con others
and missing is what happens if you find
yourself right at the center of that and
how do you get out of it people have
been obsessed with murder and kidnapping
and scary things next door forever we're
just doing what Agatha Christie did in a
very 21st century medium
there's even more twists and turns in
the first one it's a thriller that has
real scary elements to it the whole film
is constantly Twisted upon twist upon
twist it's a really fun experience to
have in a theater
I'm not giving up on my mom missing
really PG-13 exclusively in theaters
[Music]